a guard of honor from today's heroes to
one of yesterday's thanks to them Albert
chambers as beaten Coburg 19 and is
still hoping to celebrate his 100th
birthday in July for the staff that
treated him nothing but praise Albert
was serving with the Coldstream Guards
in the Second World War when he was
wounded and spent three years as a
prisoner of war in Stalag 11b before
being liberated his latest battle with
an unseen enemy only lasted three weeks
but was just as dangerous now recovered
he's back at his home of 72 years
resting how does it feel to be home
happy how are the nurses what are you
looking forward to now quite weekend the
widower for 19 years since he lost his
wife Laura
Albert's grandson Steven is now taking
care of him during his recovery for the
family it's been a difficult few weeks
tired weary emotionally kind of broken
but delighted that he's back in his
house just want to make sure he's
comfortable for the weekend and you know
Layton recuperate a little bit and get
over get over what he's gone free right
so yeah I mean he's always been our hero
right yeah he's been a hero you know
three years in a prisoner of war camp
doesn't talk about it like that most but
most that generation don't lend his life
in a very positive way yeah he's always
been my hero
[Applause]
Albert's neighbors have been rooting for
him to join his treatment in technical
range hospital
so it was perhaps no surprise that they
insisted on a little victory lap of the
cul-de-sac as they gave him a very
fitting hero's welcome
face aboard Sky News Doncaster